[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا ندد ابو محمد الجولاني
زعيم جبهه فتح الشام بالاتفاق الامريكي
الروسي بشان سوريا واتهم في مقابله خاصه
مع الجزيره الولايات المتحده وروسيا
والمبعوث الدوليه الى سوريا ستفن ديمستورا
تواطئ مع نظام الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
من اجل تصفيه الثوره السوريه نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما مدى دقه تقييم الجولاني لخطوره
الاتفاق الروسي الامريكي بشان سوريا على
المعارضه
السوريه وما مدى وجاهه اتهامات جبهه فتح
الشام للولايات المتحده بالتامر على
الثوره السوريه والسعي
لتصفيتها
في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره وفي اول رد فعل
له على الاتفاق الروسي الامريكي بشان
سوريا ندد ابو محمد الجولاني زعيم جبهه
فتح الشام بهذا الاتفاق واتهم الولايات
المتحده وروسيا والمبعوث الدوليه الى
سوريا ستفان دي مستوره بالتواطئ مع نظام
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد واضاف الجولاني
ان هناك مخططا واضحا لهؤلاء هدفه استسلام
الفصائل المسلحه التي تقاتل النظام وتفريغ
الثوره السوريه من مضمونها كحراك شعبي
هدفه الحريه والكرامه للشعب السوري هناك
مخطط يعني واضح
المعالم على النظام ان يقوم بحصار حلب ثم
يخرج اتفاق روسي امريكي ثم يخرج ديمستورا
ليعلن عن ادخال
مساعدات مساعدات انسانيه
ف قضيه الشام اصبحت قضيه واضحه بشكل كبير
جدا الاتفاق الروسي الامريكي هو اتفاق
امني عسكري بحت لا يعني يفضي في في في
النظر الى الحل السياسي يفضي الى
الاستسلام يعني
يدفع الفصائل المسلحه الى الاستسلام فقط
هذا هو الحل السياسي الامم المتحده تشرف
على حصار مدينه حلب ولم تنتفض اطلاقا
اثناء مكان الميليشيات الرافضيه والشيعيه
والايرانيه والعراقيه واللبنانيه كانت
تتقدم في حصار حلب وهو كان يشرف وينت ظر
هذه اللحظه قضيه اهل الشام هي قضيه ثوره
وقضيه مبادئ وقضيه اسلام ودين وحفاظ على
اهل
السنه ليست هي
قضيه حليب للاطفال وقضيه مواد غذائيه تدخل
الى الى الناس في وقت معين اهل الشام
عندما خرجوا في المظاهرات قالوا الموت ولا
المذله وهم يعنون ذلك وتحملوا قصف
البراميل وتحملوا هدم البيوت وتحملوا
التشريد على ان لا يذلوا لهذا النظام
الطاغ
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين من لندن
الكاتب والاعلامي السوري المعارض بسام
جعاره ومن واشنطن ماثيو مكينس المسؤول
السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه وابدا بك سيد مكانس الحقيقه
يعني هذا هذا الاتفاق وابدا باليد بسام
جعاره في الواقع الجولاني في هذا الاتفاق
يقول ان هنالك مؤامره امريكيه روسيه
لتصفيه المعارضه السوريه
اي في ضمن وعدد لذلك اسبابا كثيره اولا ما
هو رايك في مدى دقه مثل هذا
التقييم سؤال لي ام للضيف لسيد بسام جعاره
نعم
لك اهلا اهلا اهلا بك يعني دعني اقول
بدايه اطل الشيخ ابو محمد الجيلاني اليوم
اطلاله الواثق من نفسه من شعبه من
الانتصار على هذا الاتفاق المؤامره واقول
مؤامره بعيدا عن نظريه المؤامره منذ
اللحظات الاولى بل قبل الاعلان عن الاتفاق
عن الاتفاق كنا نقول ان امريكا وروسيا
تحضران منذ تسعه اشهر لهذا الاتفاق حاولوا
كسر اراده الشعب السوري حاولوا قهر الشعب
السوري حاولوا كل شيء ولم يستطيعوا جاء
حزب الله جاءت ايران جاءت الميليشيات ثم
جاءت روسيا وقالت انها ستبقى ثلاثه اشهر
والان مر عام على الغزو الروسي وفشل الان
جاء الدور الامريكي الواضح والصريح اراد
ابو محمد الجولاني ان يقول صراحه ان
امريكا وروسيا تريدان كسر اراده الشعب
السوري قهر الشعب السوري اعاده انتاج نظام
بشار الاسد اختزلوا الثوره
بطريقه بمساعدات انسانيه نعم هو قال ذلك
بالفعل مساعدات انسانيه لكن ما مدى دقه
هذا التقييم في را ت
تمام تقييم دقيق جدا قراءه واقعيه ليس
فيها اي مبالغه بل اعتقد لو اتيح المجال
او الوقت بشكل افضل لا استفاض بالشرح
نستطيع ان نستفيد بالشرح ان نتحدث ماذا
تريد امريكا يعني طيله السنوات السابقه
كانت اوساط امريكيه تقول انه يجب على
امريكا ارغام النظام على قبول حل سياسي من
خلال دعم المعارضه ولكن الان بعد هزيمه
الروس والايرانيين والجميع جاء الامريكان
ليعزز كفه بشار دعني اذكر فقط ما قالته
جريده مجله فورين بوليسي قالت انه تحالف
غير نزيه واشنطن بوست قالت انه يعزز موقف
الاسد يعني ما في داعي نشرح التفاصيل
الامر واضح اذا لم يكن هنالك تامر امريكي
روسي لتصفيه المعارضه ودعني هنا اسال ضيفي
ايضا من واشنطن السيد ماثيو مكينس مسؤول
سابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه اذا لم
يكن هنالك بالفعل تامر روسي امريكي على
تصفيه القضيه تصفيه الثوره السوريه تصفيه
المعارضه المسلحه بحيث تكون مجرد طعام
ولبن اطفال كما قال السيد كيري افضل من لا
شيء اذا لم يكن هذا هو الواقع لماذا لم
تاخذ واشنطن ولا موسكو بعين الاعتبار راي
المعارضه السوريه الحليفه له في تصنيف
الفصائل الذي خلصت اليه موسكو وواشنطن
اعتقد ان الامريكان
والروس
كليهما يحاولان ان يخلص نفسهما من هذا
الوضع القائم فانا نظرت الى هذا الاتفاق
الذي عقد مؤخرا وهو اعتراف من الجانب
الروسي بانهم على الارجح لن
ينجحوا في المستقبل القريب في ساحات
المعارك كما يتمنون وايضا اعتراف من
الامريكان و انهم خاصه لان الرئيس
اوباما وادارته على وشك يوصل الى نهايه
مدتهم فيرون انهم ل يستطيع ان يشاهدوا
نجاح كامل للثوره كما كان يتمنى الامريكان
او يعتقدون قبل اربع او خمس سنوات
وبالتالي فهم حقيقه يريدون ايجاد بطريقه
ما طريقه لوقف القتال بالتوصل الى اتفاق
سياسي كما هو باي حال واعتقد ان ذلك يعني
اي من الجانبين جانبين لن يحقق الاهداف
السياسيه التي ارادها وهذا ما اتفقت عليه
ووافقت عليه واشنطن وفي الوقت ذاته هذا
الهدف ايضا صعب جدا للتحقيق وذلك بسبب
تداخل هذه المجموعات المعارضه المختلفه
واندماجها مع فتح الشام وتنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه يعني ليست هنك فئل نبرها لو
تسمح
لي
ليست هنالك فصائل منضمه الى تنظيم الدوله
تنظيم الدوله وحده واضح كهدف واضح للجميع
لكن المشكله في المعارضه الاخرى والفصائل
الاخرى لماذا لم تصر واشنطن على على سبيل
المثال على رحيل حزب الله وعلى استهدافه
ايضا وهو مصنف امريكيا كمنظمه ارهابيه
وسبق له ان قتل جنودا
امريكيين كما اصرت موسكو على تصنيف فتح
الشام كمنظمه ارهابيه واستهدافها وهي لم
تقتل امريكيا واحدا بل قالت انها لن تنفذ
اي عمليات خارج خارج
سوريا الواقع اعتقد انا شخصيا انا
ادعم موضوع شمول حزب الله والكثير من
المجموعات المليشيات الشيعيه ضمن هذه
الاتفاقيه رغم انني افترض الى حد ما انه
لو ان قوات بشار ل تصر واشنطن على
ذلك لماذا لم يصر السيد كيري في لقاءاته
العديده المطوله لماذا لم يصر كيري الذي
كان يجلس بالعشر ساعات مع لافروف لماذا لم
يصر على ذلك اذا كان هذا رايك وانت خبير
انت مسؤول سابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه
ان هذا امر انا اعتقد كان ينبغي على
الرجاح ان يحصل ويتحقق ضمن الاتفاق ولكن
الصعوبه والتحدي في ذلك هو ان الحكومه
الامريكيه حاليا قلقه بشكل كبير حول تجنب
اي مواجهه مباشره مع ايران التي شانها ان
تؤثر على الاتفاق النووي مع ايران لان
الاتفاق النووي هذا اصبح هو الموضوع
الرئيسي بين ويات المتحده وايران وكل شيء
اخر بما ذلك سوريا اصبح شيء ثانوي ان
السياسات الامريكيه في معارضه ق مجموعات
شديده مثل حزب الله وحرس الثوره الاسلامي
وغيرها ذلك لازال قائما ولكنه اصبح امرا
ثانويا لحد كبير وبالتالي هذه الامور قد
اجلت حاليا انا اعتقد مع الاسف قد اجلت
ويبدو ان الثوره السوريه والقضيه السوريه
بمجملها هي مجرد ورقه تلعب بها الولايات
المتحده كما يلعب لاعبون اخرون سيد بسام
جعاره هل يمكن ان نقول بقلب مطمئن ان
هنالك معايير واضحه وعادله للتصنيف ام ان
الامر يخضع لاراده الكبيرين الروسي
والامريكي ورؤيته لهذا الشخص او هذه
المجموعه انها ارهابيه او غير ارهابيه او
للمصالح المشتركه بين الطرفين او
للتحالفات الاقليميه
او للرؤيه الشخصيه يعني لو واحد نسي يحلق
اداء انه ممكن يصنف ارهابيا في في في لحظه
من اللحظات هل هنالك هذه المعايير في
رايك يعني اسمح لي اقول بكل وضوح الامر لا
علاقه له على الاطلاق بالاتفاق النووي مع
ايران بدليل امريكا منذ اربع سنوات تسمح
لايران بارسال مرتزقه وسلاح رغم وجود قرار
اممي يمنع ارسال السلاح خارج ايران ويمنع
ارسال المرتزقه منعت اقامه ح منطقه حزر
جوي منعت اقامه منطقه امنه عندما كان
السوار يتقدمون كانت تضغط على الاشقاء
لمنع وصول السلاح اليهم جمدت الجبهه
الجنوبيه بعد ان وصلوا الى مشارف الغوطه
الغربيه عندما اطلقوا باتجاه الساحل
اوقفته في خمس حالات منعت امريكا سقوط
نظام بشار الاسد بمعنى ليس كما يقول ضيفك
ان امريكا كانت متعاطفه او مؤيده للثوره
السوريه منذ اليوم الاول بدا التامر بعدين
كل تصنيفات امريكا لا تعنينا على الاطلاق
يعني هل فتح الشام ارهابيه وبشار الاسد
اللي قتل مليون سوري واستخدم الكيماوي
وقال اوباما خط احمر استخدمه 138 مره بشكل
موثق هو ليس ارهابيا حزب الله الحر الثوري
الايراني دعني اقول اكثر من ذلك في معركه
جنوب حلب الاخيره كان طيران تحالف يقصف
الشباب جيش الفتح في الراموس وهذا امر
مثبت ومؤكد بمعنى اخر امريكا كانت تكمل
الدور الروسي كان الروس يقتلون وكانت
امريكا تلعب على الجانب الاخر دعني على
سبيل المثال اوضح ماذا جرى منذ اسبوعين
وهذا لم يطرق اليه الشيخ ابو محمد الولاني
عندما وصل توحد الفصائل الى نهايته تقريبا
تحت اسم مسمى جبه الجماعه تدخلت امريكا
ومارست ضغوطا كبرى وروسيا على الطرف
المقابل تمارس ضغوطا كبرى وتدفع الاموال
وتفعل كل كل شيء ولكن باكد لك تماما ان
شاء الله الفصائل ستتوحد وسيكون هو الرد
الطبيعي على هذه المؤامره اللي بدي اقوله
بكل وضوح التامر الامريكي اشرس والعن من
التامر الروسي نحن نكتوي بالتامر الامريكي
يعني كيري كان يقول انه جلب الهدنه من اجل
وقف الدماء ولكن هذا الاتفاق الامني
العسكري يعني اساله المزيد من الدماء ماذا
يعني قصف مدن تحت مسمى قصف فتح الشام حتى
في المؤتمر الصحفي كان لافروف يقول كان
يقول جماعات ارهابيه وليس جماعه بمعنى اخر
القصف سيطال الجميع وباكد لك تماما في
حالات كثيره سابقه قصفت امريكا الجميع
سنتحدث عن مساله توحيد الفصائل لان هذه
نقطه في محورنا الثاني في هذا الحوار فاصل
قصير مشاهدينا نناقش بعده مدى دقه اتهامات
الجولاني لواشنطن بالسعي لتصفيه الثوره
السوريه نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه من
ما وراء الخبر زعيم جبهه فتح الشام ابو
محمد الجولاني اوضح في مقابلته مع الجزيره
ان جبهته تسعى للاندماج مع فصائل معارضه
اخرى وشدد على اهميه الوحده بين الفصائل
السوريه داعيا الى انشاء كيان موحد في
سوريا يمثل من وصفهم باهل السنه ويدافع
عنهم عسكريا
وسياسيا جبهه فتح الشام اخذت خطوات كما
تعلم نحن كنا جبهه نصره وكان هناك ارتباط
وما الى ذلك والان تاخذنا خطوات كثيره ومع
كل هذا تصر امريكا على استهداف ليس لان
لديها ارتباط او ليس لديها ارتباط بتنظيم
معين وانما لانها قوه فاعله في الساحه تقف
عائق امام المشروع السياسي الذي يفضي الى
استسلام اهل الشام فهذا هو السبب الوحيد
في واي فصيل من فصائل الساحه
الشاميه يقوم بهذا الدور سواء في ظل وجود
جبهه فتح الشام او في عدم وجودها سيلقى
نفس المصير وهناك الحجج الكثيره
التي يقوم
عليها النظام الدولي او هذه الدول الكبرى
في التصنيف وما الى ذلك
ونناقش هذا الموضوع ايضا مع ضيفين في هذه
الحلقه من واشنطن ماثيو مكينس المسؤول
السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ومن
لندن الكاتب الاعلامي السوري المعارض بسام
جعاره وابدا بك هذه المره سيد ماثيو
مكينس ما يضر واشنطن في ان تتوحد فصائل
المعارضه السوريه المسلحه على هذا المنوال
الذي تحدث عنه ابو محمد الجولاني الذي
اعلنت جبهته فك الارتباط بتنظيم القاعده
بشكل واضح وغيرت اسمها من جبه النصره الى
فتح الشام ما هي مشكله واشنطن يعني اليست
هنالك توبه لمن تعتبرهم واشنطن
ارهابيون اعتقد ان العديد منا نحن هنا من
نراقب الوضع في سوريا وتابعنا القاعده
وجبهه النصره خلال السنوات الماضيه لدينا
كلنا شكوك حول اخلاص وصدق هذه الحركه وهذا
التغيير وبالتالي لا احد في واشنطن تقريبا
يثق مثل هذا الاجراء الجديد واعتقد ان ما
نزال لدينا شكوك كبيره حول اي تجمعات او
توحيد للفصائل بهذا النوع ان هذه الصفقه
من شانها ان تقوم بواحد من شيئين اما ان
ستدفع وتجمع كل المعارضه سويه ولهذا السبب
فان روسيا تحب هذا الاتفاق اي انه بحيث
تستطيع استهداف الجميع اما هم او حتى
الامريكان و او انها ستجزى
المعارضه وهذا ما يريده الامريكان ت ان
تفصل عناصر جبهه النصر السابقين عن الثوار
المعارضه ومما يجعل المعارضه ككل اضعف
واكثر قدره على السيطره عليها لدفعه من
المجيء الى مائده المفاوضات وبالتالي لحد
ما لهذا السب روسيا راضيه عن هذا الاتفاق
وسيكون صعب جدا فص وهذه المجموعات ولكن حل
هناك اسئله صعبه الاجابه عليها حول كان
يمكن ان يجتمعوا ويقوموا هذا الاتفاق
تماما ام هل يستطيعون الانفصال ومحاوله
تمييز انفسهم كل على حده بحيث يستطيع بعض
افراده المجيء الى مائد المفاوضات لحل
سياسي وترك البقيه يواصلون القتال ليستهدف
من قبل روسيا وامريكا واي قوه ستكون لهم
اذا جاؤوا الى مائده المفاوضات
مفتت ماذا يمكن ان يحققوا ل الشعب السوري
بعد كفاح ونضال ودماء خمس
سنوات الناحيه النظريه هذه صفقه ومره اخرى
اقول ان لدي شكوك كثيره حول نجاح هذه هذا
الاتفاق لكن من الناحيه النظريه هذه
المجموعات
التي تقول بانها انها لا علاقه لها بفتح
الشام ومن تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه سيكون
لهم سيحظون بحمايه امريكيه او ربما حمايه
تركيه او
غيرها ويحصلون على هذا الدعم اثناء
مفاوضات او عند مائده المفاوضات ارجو ان
تبقى معي ايضا سيد ماثيو ماكس ف قال
الجولاني ايضا في هذه المقابله مع الجزيره
ان اهل السنه في سوريا في حاله ضياع ودفاع
عن النفس امام ما سماه بالمشروع الرافضي
وحذر من مغبه نجاح هذا المشروع على اهل
السنه في المنطقه باسرها وقال ان الولايات
المتحده تحاول ان تفعل الان في سوريا ما
فعلته في العراق قبل 20
عاما اهل السنه في في في مرحله في حاله
ضياع ودفاع عن بقاء نحن لم نعد ندافع عن
قرى ومدن نحن اليوم اصبحنا في مرحله دفاع
عن وجود هكذا حال اهل السنه في الشام وهذا
ان نجح لا قدر الله
ا المشروع الرافضي المعادي لاهل السنه ان
نجح مشروعهم في الشام هذا سيتعدى على اهل
السنه في المنطقه باكملها فربما بعد عشر
سنوات اي ما نسمعه اليوم في الشام نسمعه
في شرق الجزيره العربيه وما كنا لا نتوقعه
في اليمن حدث بوقت
مبكر وما كنا نخشاه في العراق قبل 20 عاما
حدث وكما اراده المشروع الرافضي بالتامر
الامريكي فامريكا هي التي سلمت العراق
للرافضين في الشام طيب سيد سيد بسام جعار
الكاتب والاعلامي السوري المعارض في في
لندن هذا الخطاب الذي يصنف السوريين ما
بين روافض
وسنه
و ويريد تحالفا لاهل السنه ضد الشيعه
والروافض والعلويين على حسب تعبيره الى اي
مدى يتسق مع هدف المعارضه السوريه التي
تريد دوله مدنيه يعيش فيها كل السوريين
بسلام يعني دعني اذكر يعني لماذا نستغرب
ما قاله الشيخ ابو محمد جولاني عندما نسمع
لافروف قبل شهر يقول حرفيا ان حل القضيه
السوريه يتطلب تحقيق التوازن الديني ماذا
يعني هذا الكلام يعني قتل او طرد 15 مليون
سنه من سوريا
ماذا يعني ان تقول ايران انها تحتل اربع
عواصم عربيه ماذا يعني ان نرى المشروع
الاستيطاني الايراني يمتد كالسرطان على
الارض
السوريه الثوره السوريه انطلقت لتحقيق
العداله والديمقراطيه
والتعدديه هذا الكلام قد لا يتفق مع ذلك
لانه يريد لاهل السنه ان يكون لهم شيء في
مواجهه الشيعه والعلويين على حد
تعبيره يعني انا بس فقط عم اذكر عندما
تسمع وزير خارجيه دوله عظمى مثل روسيا
يتحدث عن تحقيق توازن ديني في سوريا اي
يعني بالترجمه يعني قتل او طرد 15 مليون
يعني هل يجب عندما نفضح الطائفيه ونتخذ
موقفا ضدها هل يعني هذا اننا نمارس
الطائفيه نحن نقول منذ زمن طويل ان
المعركه واحده في صنعاء وفي بغداد وفي
دمشق وهي فعلا معركه واحده معركه واحده
هناك مشروع استيطان ايراني في المنطقه
يمتد لا يعني لايشم هذه المنطقه فقط بل
اكثر من ذلك منذ ايام كنت تسمع كيف كانوا
يريدون تدويل الحج ويهددون مكه كل يوم
امام هذا الخطاب ماذا تريد يعني هل نقول
لهم اضربوا خدنا الايسر يعني استاذ بان
جعاره هذا الخطاب يمثل المعارضه
السوريه انا لا اقول يمثل المعارضه
السوريه ولكن اقول عندما نسمع الخطاب
الايراني والخطاب الروسي وما يجري على
الارض فعليا بمشاركه الامم المتحده من
تطهير ديني فيجب ان لا تتوقع الناس ان
يقولوا كلاما هادئا ومعقولا المؤامره
واضحه امريكا على المكشوف لا تعتبر الشيعه
اعداء تعتبر سنه ارهابيين تعتبرهم جميعا
هذا ليس كلامي هذا ما يجري على الارض
اليوم يعني عندما تترك الوق نقطه وج حرس
الثوري الايراني هذه نقطه وجيه اريد ان
اتوجه بها الى ضيفي من واشنطن كذلك السيد
ماثيو مكينس يعني الذي ينظر الى الواقع
العراق سلم لقوه في اغلبها شيعيه الحوثي
في اليمن يعبث باليمن كما يشاء ويسيطر على
الحكم الان وهو اقليه شيعيه وليس اغلبيه
وليس شيعيه اثنا عشريه بالدرجه المتعارف
عليها لكن حينما ياتي الامر الى
سوريا لم لم تتخذ الولايات المتحده اي
خطوات لتسليم الحكم لاهل سوريا واغلبهم من
العرب
السنه
اعتقد انه من وجهه نظر
امريكيه ان الاوضاع هذه الثلاثه مختلفه
بعضها عن الاخر فالعراق غالبيه السكان فيه
شيعه وبالتالي من الطبيعي فان اي نوع من
ترتيبات السلطه تكون لصالح الشيعه في هذا
الوضع رغم انني اعتقد باننا لم ندفع
الجهود الايرانيه بما يكفي للسيطره
والهيمنه على النشاط السياسي في العراق
اما في اليمن نعم الحوثيون اقليه
والايرانيون لا غير مهيمنين هناك لكن
يحاولون ابعاد اليمن من فلك السعوديه ودول
الخليج الاخرى العربيه
وذلك لخاله بامن واستقرار السعوديه اما في
سوريا فان
فان هناك عمليه تطهير جاريه واعاده توازن
طائفي يج حاليا واق
الايرانيين يعني لا يوجد كثير في الشرق
الاوسط من يصدق هذه القراءه الامريكيه
ولكن اريد ان اسال السيد بسام جعاره اخيرا
هل فعلا ما قاله الجولاني عن ان واشنطن
وضعت نفسها هي وروسيا في مواجهه الشعب
السوري بمثل هذا الاتفاق الى اي مدى يعتبر
ذلك
دقيقا
بص كلام دقيق كان يجب ان يقال منذ اربع
سنوات وكنا نلوم الجميع لانه ما يقول ما
يقاله الجولاني اليوم كان يجب ان يقال
صراحه ان نقول للعالم كله ان امريكا عدو
الشعب السوري عندما تقصف قريه علويه تتدخل
امريكا وعددما تبادل
المدن ذك لماذا تتحدثون اكرك شكرا جزيلا
الكاتب او الاعلام السوري المعارض في لندن
بسام جعاره واشكر ضيفي من واشنطن ماثو ماك
المسؤول السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
وبهذا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج م وراء الخبر دمتم في امان الله
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء